what's going on everyone it is axl beats
here for anime uproar and with demon
slayer in full swing right now i wanted
to take a moment to give you all some
details of the story or the surrounding
factors that you might have missed when
watching or reading be sure to let me
know how many you knew at the end if you
enjoy this video and you want to see
more demon slayer content on this
channel remember to leave a like as well
as a comment down below it only takes a
second but it really does help with the
youtube algorithm and of course if you
haven't subscribed to anime uproar make
this the video that you do so by
clicking that bell and selecting all
notifications
you can also follow anime uproar on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar or
you can follow myself at excellionyt of
course this video will contain some
demon slayer spoilers but for the most
part i will try to avoid any really big
ones so that any anime only viewers can
still enjoy this video with that said
let's get into it so our first fact
isn't so much a detail about the story
itself however it's something i found to
be pretty fun so i included it nezuko's
japanese voice actor akarikito has some
interesting links with her character
firstly they are both exactly five feet
tall but more importantly and almost
impressively the kanji representing ki
in the voice actress's name actually
translates to demon which is pretty
fitting for the character senitsu is
famous for being a womanizer or at least
obsessed with the idea of finding a wife
especially early in the series which is
kind of funny when you consider that his
family name agatsuma translates to my
wife the dude is so down bad that it's
literally in his name while we're
talking about zenitsu we can also
mention that he is the only non-hashira
to both create a new breathing form
and defeat an upper rank moon alone even
amongst the hashira these are pretty
impressive feats finally the last thing
i want to mention about this character
is the legend of zenitsu an
autobiographical memoir which details
the entirety of the demon slayer story
and which is presumably how modern
people know about what happened even if
most people believe that it's just a
bunch of lies
amongst all of the demon slayers inosuke
is probably the most hated by those who
support the demon slayer core
specifically the people who make their
uniforms and swords become
extraordinarily upset with him as they
see him literally tearing apart their
hard work in front of them ripping his
clothes off and chipping away at the
swords they just made you probably won't
see nosuke's crow with him very often
and that's because the bird tends to
avoid him as a result of almost being
eaten by him
18 times
while tonjiro is a pretty easy name to
say inosuke has called him 10 different
names so far including ganpachiro
kamaboko gengoro shakariki tantaro
itadaki kenjironago
tangorohamadou jangoro amaro mongiro
kantaro santaro and once in a dream
where he was a raccoon even being called
ponjiro and to be fair some of these are
almost close ish
genya is the only demon slayer to not
have access to any breathing style and
that's probably because he prefers to
not use his sword and instead relies on
a gun
which
yeah sure i guess that's fair regardless
though genya uses something called
repetitive action as opposed to total
concentration breathing and to be fair
if i had to choose a breathing style i
think shotgun style would be pretty
effective
kanao is the only example of a suguko
that we get in the series this is a
demon slayer that has been selected to
be the successor to a living hashira
ironically we are told that they tend to
use the same breathing styles as the
hashira that they work under but in
kano's case which is again the only one
that we've seen we have a flower
breather who is a suguko to an insect
breather in shinobu kanao aoi and
shinobu all have different uniforms than
mitsuri despite mitsuri supposedly
having the standard for female slayers
apparently maida masao a perverted
uniform sewer for the demon slayer core
makes them specifically to be
open-chested however upon seeing that
shinobu poured oil onto her uniform and
threw matches on it in front of maida
telling kano and ali to do the same
murad the most recurring background
demon slayer was in the same final
selection as sabito and giu he was also
apparently given a compliment from a
girl he liked about his hair and since
then has put extra effort into making it
look perfect hotaru the sword smith for
the demon slayer core is typically seen
in a hyotoko mask usually described as
having a puckered face and often
different sized eyes
while there are different stories for
this in different regions of japan in
iwate where i lived for a year the myth
was that there was a boy with an odd
face who had the ability to make gold
from his belly button if someone died he
would show up at their house with a
hyotoko mask and put it on their
fireplace this in hopes of bringing
their family good fortune going forward
much like hotaro orokodaki also wears a
mask this is because he has a very
gentle face and demons would make fun of
him otherwise his mask is based on a
tengu a mythological yokai which were
sometimes considered to be shinto gods
most relevantly in the story of minamoto
yoshitsune a young boy named ushiwaka
maru is taught swordsmanship by atengu
to get revenge against a clan that
killed his father which is pretty
similar to orokodaki training tanjiro to
avenge his family and protect nezuko
jigiro was the only hashira to not have
his title based purely on his breathing
style while he was the thunder hashira
and he did use thunder breathing he was
typically referred to as the roaring
hashira which instead refers to the
sound that thunder makes and when you
consider that sound breathing comes from
thunder breathing it's a pretty cool
link kane might have been one of the
strongest hashira in the series while
others are definitely powerful in their
own right we often see the higher
echelon of the upper moons being taken
down by multiple demon slayers akkasa
doma and kokushibo are each individually
miles beyond what the hashira have to
offer however kane was able to battle
with upper moon 2 doma until sunrise on
equal footing while she ultimately would
die from her injuries it still says
quite a bit about her that she could
hold her own against doma for so long
especially when you consider that
rengoku who was considered extremely
powerful among the hashira was barely
able to keep up with upper moon 3 for a
night
shinjuro rengoku is a character that a
lot of people have issues with he's just
kind of a jerk all around and while we
do see a softer side from him in
specific scenes especially when we look
at him actually coming to terms with his
dead wife or dead son it's hard to deny
that he's one of the most hateable
characters in the series and this is
only pushed further when we learn in the
first handbook that he hates animals so
much that he wouldn't let kyojiro get a
pet because of course this character
hates animals you may have noticed that
the rengoku family has a very
distinctive hairstyle and apparently
this is caused by an ancestor who ate
too much tempura i'm not sure how this
dyed their hair but it looks pretty cool
so maybe i'll give it a go kyojiro's
mother ruka has very unusual eyes during
pregnancy in the rengoku family the
women traditionally stare into flames
for hours on end this in hopes that it
will inspire their child to grow
stronger ruka apparently did this so
much that it actually dyed her eyes
crimson giyutomioka has a spinoff which
is fittingly called giyutomioka
the amount of wisteria within shnobu's
body has been retconned by gotoge
originally being said to have 70 times
the lethal amount for a demon however it
was later corrected to be 700 times
shinobu also has the most distant
breathing style that we know about from
the original sun style insect breathing
comes from flower breathing which comes
from water breathing which comes from
sun breathing making her three times
removed from the original style the next
set which is two times removed include
things like flower sun mist serpent love
and beast breathing and finally the
original six deviations were water flame
thunder stone wind and moon breathing
mid-city's hair has a unique color to it
and this is apparently because she ate
too much sakura mochi interestingly this
kind of parallels how the rengoku family
received their hair color as well which
is kind of fun when you consider that
love breathing which mitsuru uses stems
from flame breathing which the rengoku
family uses
these slits on obani's mouth are likely
a reference to heath ledger's the joker
wait nope wrong notes uh sorry it is a
reference to the kuchi saka-ona or the
split-mouthed woman
this woman is known to cover her face
with a mask and have long black hair and
pale skin pretty fitting to obani the
myth surrounding this yokai is that it
would approach men and ask if they
thought that she was beautiful if they
said no she would kill them if they said
yes she would reveal her mouth and ask
them again again if they said no she
kills them if they say yes
she cuts their face to look like hers
the only apparent loophole is to say
that she looks average or to distract
her but either way it's a pretty
nightmare situation tsonomy stops
maidamaso from harassing the female
demon slayers and he does so by scaring
him to the point of wetting his pants
gyome has a connection to kaigaku
kaigoku used to be one of the orphans
that gilmay took care of at the temple
gyome is also the only hashira to not
use a sword instead relying on a chained
axe with a spiked ball at the end
muichiro and gyome both rank as the
fastest developing hashira each becoming
a hashida only two months after picking
up a sword for the first time which is
insane when you consider that tanjiro
trained with rokodaki for two years
tengen and jigoro are the only known
hashira to retire due to disability
rather than age or death
interestingly jigoro was a thunder
breathing user while tengen is a sound
breathing user which of course derives
from thunder breathing each hashira has
a specific region that they have to
protect
the leader of the demon slayers kageyau
ubuyashiki inherited his position at the
age of 4 after his father took his own
life at 19. furthermore all of the other
male siblings that he had died in suit
this all pushes into the fact that the
entire family had been cursed for
birthing the original demon muzon over a
thousand years ago this interestingly
ties muzon and the demon slayer core
together very very intimately regardless
every man in the ubu yashiki family
would meet their death before the age of
30 while every woman would have to be
married off or change their names when
they become 13 otherwise they will also
be killed or die
at that point
it's definitely an interesting curse to
deal with in a series that reflects the
series antagonist who fears mortality
pretty directly
in contrast to the ubu yoshiki family
muzon is effectively immortal outside of
being caught in sunlight his primary
goal is to achieve the ability to walk
under the sun and truly become immortal
and overcome the fear and trauma that he
dealt with having been a very weak and
sick human to overcome the sun muzon has
to find the blue spider lily a flower
which rarely blooms and even then only
blooms during the day this altogether
makes his quest kind of a fool's errand
yushiro and chachamaru are likely the
only demons left alive at the end of the
main demon slayer story demon slayer
pays homage to several other manga and
anime series but one of the earliest
references is probably with susumaru's
eyes which are nearly a perfect match to
sage mode narutos
yahaba is likely inspired by the tenome
or the hand eye yokai from japanese myth
this yokai was created when a blind man
was killed and on his last breath wished
to see the man who killed him he came
back to life and searched the area using
his new eyes that appeared on his hand
kyogai can be seen reading the legend of
the 8th samurai this was a film created
in the 1980s and based on a japanese
epic by kyokute bakin called nanso
satomi hakkenden this story discusses
the lives of the eight dog warriors
bound by fate to fight for the sattomi
clan against powerful lords probably
similar to the demon slayer core this is
kind of also supplemented when you
consider that all of the eight warriors
had distinct markings which ties into
demon slayers when you consider that
there are eight demon slayers who fought
against muzon and received the demon
slayer mark we are unfortunately
excluding kokushibo here as he did not
fight against luzon and obviously yeah
that's a bit nitpicky but hey let me
have this it's pretty fun and like
there's a bunch of other solid
connections in this list one goofy ones
alright most of the lower moon names
were introduced in the first handbook
this includes kamanue mukagol wakuraba
and rokuro rui is another character with
a name that reflects his actions rui in
this case means to accumulate and when
you consider that he is one of the few
demons other than muzon to build up a
group of followers it makes a lot of
sense
daki's sash-like neck is likely inspired
by the roku rokubi a yokai that mostly
looks human but can stretch or detach
its neck freely daki and gyoko have been
claimed to get special treatment from
muzon in particular this is because they
act as a great source of income for him
daki is able to make money in the
entertainment district while gyoko can
make money by selling his pots for
massive sums of cash muzon lives a
pretty lavish life so he needs some way
to pay for it gyotaro is interestingly
enough the real upper moon 6 not daki
kaigaku was able to master most of the
thunder breathing forms however he was
unable to master the first form though
unconfirmed this could be a result of
him having his scabbard on his back as
opposed to his waist where the form
tends to launch from kagaku also has an
interesting choice in accessories with
his tome away bracelets and necklace
these change color between his human and
demon lies going from yellow to dark
blue which shows his fall from good to
bad the tomoy is also represented on
raijin the god of lightning's drums
which alludes to the thunder breathing
style gyoko is the only upper moon that
we did not get a backstory for in the
manga
nakime upper moon 4 and kyogai former
lower moon 6 each use sound-based blood
demon arts which can affect their
environments
we've seen one member of the upper moons
and one member of the lower moons see
their loved ones after death these being
rui and akasa akas attacks tend to be
named after fireworks a reference to his
lost love koyuki to see fireworks
together
on a similar note akaza is also the only
demon given specific permission to not
fight or kill women by muzon finally
akaza is also the only demon moon to
fight barehanded doma is the one who
turned daki and gyotoro into demons
and finally kokushibo has been
challenged for the title of upper moon 1
3 times usually he opts to absorb those
he defeats however the third time was
with akuza and he enjoyed the challenge
so much that he allowed him to live
and there you have it 50 facts all about
the demon slayer story that you might
have missed watching through again let
me know what you thought of these how
many you knew and how many you thought
were really interesting or just what
your favorite was and hey if you have
any fun demon slayer facts or things
that we might have missed let me know in
the comments because i would love to
learn more if you guys enjoyed this
video though remember to leave a like
and subscribe to anime uproar for more
great content in the future you really
do have to take the time to hit the bell
and then select the option that says all
notifications i know it's a hassle but
it is just how youtube works finally you
can also follow us at animeupper on
twitter and instagram or you can follow
myself at excellionyt but for now thank
you guys so much for watching i hope you
enjoyed the video and until next time
remember to stay excellent
[Music]
you